the battle for 2020 is officially on as
president Trump holds his first campaign
rally in El Paso Texas tonight the
president taking aim at Democrat bado
O'Rourke for holding a counter rally in
the city as he makes his big push for
border security we're going to El Paso
we have a line that is very long already
I mean you see what's going on and I
understand our competitors got a line
too but it's a tiny little line of
course they'll make it sound like they
had more people than we do that's not
going to happen but we're going there
for a reason we're going there to keep
our country safe this comes as the field
of Democratic contenders gets even more
crowded Trump mocking Elizabeth Warren
for the DNA debacle hanging over her
campaign announcement the president also
poking fun at senator Amy Klobuchar for
announcing her candidacy in a snowstorm
Warren firing back against the
president's ancestry attacks the time we
get to 2020 Donald Trump may not even be
President
[Applause]
in fact he may not even be a free person
and Klobuchar addressing reports she
can't find a campaign manager because
she's difficult to work for
I am tough I push people that is true
but my point is is that I have high
expectations for myself I have high
expectations for the people that work
for me
and I have high expectations for this
country and the kemal air is also making
some headlines today for this comment
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey listen I think that it gives a lot
of people joy we'll get to that in a
second but you and Amy Klobuchar have a
lot in common very difficult to work
exactly I like her more and more than
where I hear about her she's got the
funnest name to say clover char you've
got 24 hours Club azshara to find the
missing kid when you're fired anyway
she's got she's got like a 1970s cop
show name but I want to talk I just
talked about and also it's not sexist to
point out that she's got a bad temper
they did that with John McCain and they
did it with Bob Dole and they do it with
Trump so it ain't sexist in fact it's
sexist not to do it do you have the tape
of Liz with the kid oh yes this is
Elizabeth
whatever announcements this weekend so
here's this is here's the problem with
Lisbon yeah is Warren here's the problem
Liz one she's like a professional
wrestler who over acts in each scene and
then instructs you to believe in the
sport no matter what she is a politician
who pretends to be a politician wherever
she goes and it's so fake and especially
in the era of Trump where he rejected
all of that for all the trimmings of
being a politician they didn't care it
exposes her folly even more as a
world-class phony she is a professional
wrestler
and you see all the tricks let me grab
this kid and then saying like you know
what did she just say he won't be a free
person right just say free man okay save
a syllable Klobuchar and we also have
Kamala Harris admitting to smoking weed
what do you think I think it makes her a
total hypocrite I think now conveniently
she's one of those people who's hopped
on board the cannabis Caravan but in
reality people in her state of
California have suffered under some of
her punitive actions as Attorney General
and she even cackle daffy you years ago
when asked about legalization of
cannabis in the great state of
California this is someone who is not
supported legalization she has locked up
a bunch of nonviolent offenders and is
not lobbied for their release when she
absolutely could have she misused her
power she was horrible on civil rights
and right now it's just a popularity
grab but who wouldn't cackle with
affection of my friend Charlemagne I
thought yeah Juan now you have another
reason to vote for Carmela she smokes
grass that's why I think they've
legalized I was telling you guys I was
in San Francisco no I think it look I
don't by the way I don't think that was
a fair thing that you said Kennedy
because guess what people hang on please
enforce the law that was her job as an
officer for the state of California her
job was to enforce the law not to make
it up and she did it she enforced it
selectively enforced law and selectively
she said it or using it I mean that's
the lawsuit did enforce it but I would
say the people who go after her on
charges of selective prosecution are way
off on this it's almost to me and this
comes from the left more than there
right the same because you were a good
prosecutor you can't be a Democrat how
crazy is that well don't call yourself a
progressive prosecutor if your record
shows the complete opposite I just think
she was a very good prosecutor and I
think well anyway I'll leave that I'll
leave that up to you but I will say I
think the news today is about Trump in
El Paso because our own brain room that
you like to cite jesse has said violent
crime wasn't higher before the wall in
El Paso
and it was so glad you brought that I
wanted to bring this around it is such a
shame no it's not here it is here's the
fact once you go right alright in 2009
when the wall was erected in El Paso
about 3300 violent crimes reported last
available year statistics were out 2016
about 2,600 violent crimes reported
that's about a 20 percent drop in
violent crime since the wall has been
erected in El Paso Rahman you're sorry
not only you disagree with me you're
disagreeing with the brief this is why I
mentioned it because you had played this
farcical game before and so I went to
the Brigham they said from 6 to 11
oh six to twenty eleven violent crime
went up 17% Pokemon I'm not
cherry-picking 2006 appropriation right
so what stopped it at 2011 you can go
all the way you can go and crime went
down and you're trying to fool the
audience but the clear fact is no the
beta O'Rourke
a sheriff in El Paso the mayor and I'll
pass they'll all say this town had a low
crime rate before and after this phony
wall I'll bet the stats on my Twitter
feed and everybody can see the truth
we're definitely gonna solve this
argument today so I'm stopping it what's
interesting to me is that we had more
women announced over the weekend and
what we haven't had in a president jury
so I think we have at least five so far
that are running what's happened both on
the Democrat side and the Republican
side is there's always been one woman on
stage and there's been all of these
rules about in the senatorial races and
presidential races about how do you
approach the one woman on the stage and
now that we have four or five on the
stage it'll be interesting to see how
the Democrats play that out how they
argue with each other and so I actually
think it's a really interesting to be a
really interesting election to see the
interaction especially between the women
and can we just preempt this sort of
like catfight narrative that People
magazine and Us Weekly and all these
things will put out these women are
gonna battle they're gonna be really
tough but
politicians and they want to be the
president and can I just say one thing
about Club which is yes I was actually
intrigued hearing that she's tough on
her staff I think that is a negative at
all you're known for being very tough
very tough yes dominatrix exactly people
pay me for my service you know but the
one thing that the one thing about this
whole thing that is so beautiful and why
this is going to be the best two years
ever not only do we have a field of
democratic candidates we have ongoing
directors commentary from Donald Trump
this has never happened before we're
gonna have a president who's going to do
ongoing commentary about everybody and
his media presence is so huge that by
comparison they will seem so small he'll
be Darth Vader
they'll be Ewoks he'll be Gladys Knight
they'll be the pit that's the way it
played out over the weekend when he went
after Chloe Shar as snow man or he said
snow woman she shot back oh yeah I want
to see you staying out in the rain with
your hair I think you dodged some odd
she said that anybody else no but she
said it in response in her tweet that
he's the one with the sensitive here but
you know what I think if he goes after
those women I think they should they
fire back and I don't think that he
comes out I think that it's a it's a
joke to say he's goes after everybody I
think we learned that 2016 after John
McCain pretty hard